i was taken into a darkened room no
windows
and sat in a chair wooden chair
this arm was strapped with leather
straps to the chair
i had electrodes which they had soaked
in salt water
placed on my arms stuck on my arm and of
course my hands shot up in the air as
the electric current passed through my
body for the next 40 years of my life
whenever i recalled that i physically
shook
oh this is so high
young and beautiful that doesn't help
and you are too so nice to meet you and
you i'm carolyn carolyn
campbell two c's can you give us both a
little bit of an intro to who you are
yeah um so my name's cam ball
um i'm transgender woman so i started
transitioning
when i was 15 so i'm like 12 years into
my transition now
and yeah i get to do amazing things like
this and meet you so it's great
i'm carolyn um i'm 75 years old i passed
my birthday last week
i'm a parent
grandparent
partner
i was a secondary head teacher for 20
years
lots of other things so you're both
transgender can you explain what that
means to you
okay
when i was born um
the the nurses looked at my genitalia
and said you're a boy told my parents
you're a boy
carry on with it for me
and it is just me
sex you can look at in biological terms
one of which is chromosomes
in terms of gender these are societal
expectations
so for example
uh boys are now dressed in blue girls
are dressed in pink
up till
1930s
it was the opposite way around really
yes
gender for me in terms of a definition
and the government used it and
stonewalled to a degree use it
is that
imposed
stereotype that some things are
acceptable for men
some things are only acceptable for
women
so
it's aligning what was important to me
transgender if we want to use that word
is to make sure that
how i present myself
in terms of those societies expectations
and how i feel inside were matched
my bottom line is
that i will debate with you what sex is
i will debate with you what gender is i
will not debate with you
my identity because that's mine that's
how i would define it yeah a spectrum
yeah so you have female one side male
one side so for me i was born a male
didn't fit in that spectrum or that side
of the scale and then i haven't even
gone in the middle i've completely
jumped over to female because that's who
i am and that's what i've always been so
can you give us both a little sort of
what were your what was your childhood
like i think my childhood was
quite difficult because
when i was growing up like i just wanted
to be on hormones so bad and i wanted to
start my medical transition but i
couldn't because
there were rules in place and i was
there was like a two-year waiting list
to get hormones or even to be seen by
gender specialists so
a lot of my teenage years was waiting
waiting waiting i feel like as a trans
person your life is waiting less
just waiting to be seen waiting to be
seen but you know from that point when i
started taking hormones it was just like
euphoric because like people say gender
dysphoria i feel like i have gender
euphoria now because i can look at
myself in the mirror and just be like
i'm so happy like i've finally
matched what i've always wanted to be
and when i was growing up i just never
thought that would be possible i'm even
getting terry thinking about it but like
that is just like amazing to me my
childhood was
i was going to say slightly different
but i don't mean that it was radically
different in that i was
remember it was
decades ago
[Music]
over half a century
ago
and
i was terrified
terrified of people finding out because
i had no idea what was going on inside
my head
because there was no internet
there were no books there were no
magazines i had no idea that anyone else
in the world
felt the way that i did it it must have
felt quite like isolating because now
you can literally just go on instagram
you can go on youtube and you can find
someone that's going through the same as
you but if you're from a time when those
things didn't even exist it's like who
do you turn to
i didn't even know what hormones were
yeah at that time so i made sure that
nobody suspected how i felt
and
i got involved in rugby
uh in rugby the
toughest ugliest position to play is
when you were like really trying to be
masculine just to like i was really good
at what's going on i'm absolutely really
good at it so i played tight head prop
wall i did weight lifting judo boxing we
kind of like do these things like hide
our femininity but we end up
over compensating and being someone that
we're not
i certainly over compensated um
i was suicidal
i wanted to be cured i didn't want to
have the feelings that i had
attempted suicide when i was 16 17.
saw psychiatrists when i was 17 and
that's when the conversion practice uh
kicked in yeah that's that's really like
hard to be honest like
because it was just such a different
time and like it really upsets me like
you had to go through that
so when did you first experience
gender confusion i think i first felt
different when i was literally in the
playground and
my body was different to my friends like
i did not understand what gender meant i
used to like
be obsessed with britney spears be
obsessed with christine aguilera
then i would watch their music videos on
tv and i'd like wow i want to be like
that i want to be like a powerful
sexual woman and just like
be completely free i remember at the age
of
three or four probably four
um
[Music]
i had a sister who i invented a game
where we swap clothes
and it's never been about clothes it's
never been about makeup i i've never
wanted to be a beautiful woman because
there's absolutely no way that i could
do that you are beautiful
and
i remember from then
the confusion and the anger and the
aggression in me
and
hating myself for feeling the way that i
did
and that
was emphasized by the conversion
practice
in that it taught me that society
must think i'm wrong bad evil
um
because they were prepared to punish me
yeah and then you keep being told the
same thing absolutely start to believe
in yourself so if you're told what
you're doing is wrong what you're doing
is evil then you're gonna start to
believe that in your mind
absolutely and you have this deep dark
secret that you bury
so deep and and you just don't want it
to come out and then when you were both
younger
who was the first person you opened up
to
about how you felt
i'll let you go first
uh the first person i opened up to um
was believe it's not a vicar
um happened in a very strange
circumstance
my vicar came around to see my mum who
was out and i let him in and i was in
floods of tears and i explained to him
uh how i felt that i wanted to be cured
and he was the one who organized for me
to see a psychiatrist and the
psychiatrist then referred me to the nhs
and the nhs the treatment was the
instructor wouldn't share an electrocute
that was through the nhs it was but it
doesn't happen now yeah but
i never knew it was through nhs yes it
was i thought conversion therapy was
something like on the side no but that
is crazy to me
well yes yes crazy to me and of course
it doesn't work but the vicar was the
first person i told uh even before my
parents i think i remember when i can't
remember what age but
someone said to me oh you do realize you
look like a girl and i was like
yeah that's the point yeah and it took
me until i was like
15.
i was like mom i don't want my haircut
anymore she was like well you look like
you look even more like a girl and i was
like yeah that's fine like i wanna
i want to and i bought some extensions
from ebay some really awful extensions
and i was like well i did buy these
extensions right away um and she was
like i'll put them on and then i put
them on and then she was like
wow
and then she just really helped me you
know go to my gp and get hormones so
she's honestly like without my mom i
would never have been able to go through
to go through with my transition was the
first one you spoke to yeah
love her so much
so after you went to the victory you
referred to the nhs
and the nhs then put you through
um conversion therapy
can you talk a bit about what that what
that was what does that entail
so
don't burst into tears okay
i survived and i said exactly sorry i'm
just emotional it's the hormone okay no
that's interesting as well isn't it
the the treatment that i had the
so-called conversion therapy which got
to emphasize doesn't happen now although
conversion therapy does happen although
mentally
there is like
conversion therapy is being banned for
gay people lesbian people and bisexual
not yet but not for transgender people
hasn't yet no but it will be but trans
people aren't there's a campaign of
which i'm part of which will get i hope
trans people
uh banned for trans people i want it
stopped
for everybody it's described as barbaric
the un describe it that way
and for the government to say
there are complexities
yes there are
sort them
and that's why i'm prepared to tell my
story what happened was i was taken into
a darkened room no windows
and
sat in a chair wooden chair
this arm was strapped with leather
straps to the chair
i had electrodes which they had soaked
in salt water
placed on my arms stuck on my arm
and then opposite they showed projected
pictures of women
and they showed a picture
and then another picture
and then through the switch
unpredictable randomly it seemed and of
course my hands shot up in the air as
the electric current passed through my
body my arm didn't because it was
strapped to the chair
now
two things happened that was repeated
one is that for the next 40 years of my
life whenever i recall that i physically
shook
so i was doing an assembly with pupils
if it popped into my head i physically
shook they didn't notice
that stopped
in 2002
when i made the changes that i needed to
i don't physically shake now but what it
also did
was to emphasize to me how wrong
dirty bad i was that i deserve that sort
of treatment and even though they did
that it didn't cure me
didn't cure me because there's nothing
to cure you can change behaviors you
can't change emotions and thoughts and
and that's what happened
you know the fact that you had to go
through that i'm not going to cry
it's just horrible and
like painful tip because i'm putting
myself in your shoes
when did you
both decide to transition and can you
just tell us a little bit about what
that process involves
after you okay um
i was approaching
uh
the so-called transition aligning my
gender presentation with my gender
identity in 1994
i'd been going to charing cross
since 1987
i
managed to persuade them eventually
that i needed hormones
to try to soften my features and
give me some inkling of whether i could
present myself
as as female
because in
1994
i'd got to the stage where i needed to
decide
whether i was going to make that change
or not
and it got to the stage where i had
some breast development
[Music]
and i literally stayed awake all night
to make a decision i had to i'd taken
time off school because i just wasn't
hacking it
[Music]
and i decided that i would go back to
school
in a male role
and
went to the barbers had my hair cut
cut my nails
rang up my doctor my gp and said look i
i made this decision i will go back to
school
my union because i was a union officer
as well as a head teacher said there is
absolutely no way because it had been
all over the national papers okay so you
had transitioned nope
no i was at the stage where i had
prepared to okay right make that change
um
so as i say uh in september of 1994 it
was all over the national papers this
this freakish head
was going to have a sex change
so after that um decided i would go back
to school i had a bilateral mastectomy
uh had my breasts removed
and tried to make a go of it
and
it built up and built up and built up
and in 2002 i finally decided that that
was what i needed to do
by that time i was
bulimic
drinking heavily only at the weekends
never prior to going to work oh no not
when you're marking the homework
no
um
and
increasingly hating myself
and through that it spoiled
relationships with other people
so
that was
when i made the decision that i made
and not for one fraction of a second and
i regretted making that decision so yeah
i
decided to transition properly when i
was fifteen
so i went to my doctors and got hormones
um well i say it i went to a doctor and
got hormones it's not like that so you
go to your doctor's you then have to
speak to them about it the first doctor
i went to had no idea what i was talking
about i was waiting months for them to
get back to me never got back to me so i
changed doctors
i went to this really lovely lady who
honestly helped me so much she was like
you know i've dealt with trans um
transgender patients before
so she referred me to a
psychiatrist
and i spoke to them and then they
referred me to the gender identical neck
and then i had to have two appointments
for them
spaced out for a year
before i got my hormones
and it honestly felt like a lifetime
going through until i got the hormones i
would literally call them up every
single day black so when's my
appointment when's my appointment when's
my phone every single day and it was
like borderline harassing them because i
was so desperate for these and what sort
of hormones were prescribed campbell
were they
you know so-called blockers or were
there estrogens so i started taking
estrogen
um using tablets and then i had
um
a
injection every month in my stomach here
called zolodex or gosulin and it was
like a knitting needle and they stick it
in your stomach and release this like
synthetic thing and then that just kills
all your testosterone so i had that
every six weeks for like five years
it was so painful
like imagine yeah
i think you know when i was 17 18 i used
to look in the mirror and
not like i'd been on hormones but i
wasn't completely happy with the way i
looked i feel like hormones really
helped me
um but yeah i probably wasn't happy
until i was like 21 22
until i'd had my gender reassignment
surgery and had all of everything else
sometimes it's not even about the way
you look like it's actually about how
you feel inside and
i used to see being trans is such a bad
thing i was never tell anyone i was
trans
and i kind of like hated myself for it
so
it doesn't matter about looking in the
mirror it's about the way you feel
inside and i feel like completely
content and happy inside
and that's only been within the last few
years so
obviously right now there's a lot of
discussion
around trans rights and it's become a
sort of politicized
issue
how do we
how does how does that make you feel how
has it all made you feel these last few
years i suppose i feel like sometimes
it's crazy like you're just like reading
something and then the next article is
like a debate on your body
it's like our bodies aren't up for
debate or our bodies aren't political
with just people
and it's so tiring to see your identity
debated every single day or someone's
like
what like because you're trans
everyone's going to think you have an
opinion on everything that's translated
what do you think about trans women in
sport what do you think about trans
women and swimming like
i just sometimes i just don't want to
know the the media is
predominantly horrendous
at the moment
and i've seen it getting worse over the
last couple of years
the mail for example online i'm quite
happy to to be challenged on this
mail online
i found half a day
a fortnight ago where there wasn't a
trans article
i found the day a month ago where there
were seven trans articles or anti and
the half day that i found that there
wasn't a trans article was the queen's
jubilee and even by the afternoon
they'd found an anti-trans article
i know that there are issues
you mentioned about sport and so on
i have different views on that to many
people perhaps
[Music]
because i can still lift 200 weight
um
[Music]
because the shape of my body
200 weight for jacob reese mark
which is about 100 kilograms
um it's not to do with testosterone
just
so there is an issue
and and
the line that i would follow is that
it's up to individual sports how they
deal with it certainly in terms of
weightlifting boxing they have weight
categories so to single out trans is
just being deliberately cruel
it's not to do with testosterone
certainly but there are ways of dealing
with it and i don't think we're handling
it particularly well because we're not
being generous we're not thinking it
through
we're feeling oh let's attack them
because they're awful people
no
quite nice really
i hide it well
does the current coverage in the media
make you angry
i have trained myself over the years not
to be angry
i am
frustrated very frustrated
that people
can't see the humanity we are all human
we all deserve respect as human beings i
do find it immensely frustrating
and tiring that you have to try to
counter
what is clearly to me totally illogical
there is no reason why anyone
who doesn't know me should have even an
opinion about me why does it matter to
anyone else how i look how i live or who
i love yeah definitely i feel like
sometimes when you're trans like
people think they can ask you what they
want it's like you sign a contract and
like see your body as everyone else's so
people can ask oh do you have a penis do
you have a vagina what's this what's
this what's this and i feel like people
think they have a right to ask you what
they want really like
what everyone has is no one else's
business and if someone chooses to speak
on their experiences
then let them but
i think there's a line we've spoken
there about the the kind of abuse you've
received online and stuff like that and
that's obviously horrendous
how do you feel when people like you see
someone like ricky gervais making
comments about the trans community how
does how does someone
famous when they're talking about does
that
does that feel even worse in some ways
or how does that make you feel i feel
sorry for when i see people that are
against trans people because i'm like
well you're just going to be on the
wrong side of history in the future
because you know you see all these
articles about gay people from years ago
yes and that's what's going on with
trans people right now there is nothing
more powerful
than a word
and once it's it's a bit like an arrow
once it's loosed
you can't take it back the most unkind
people thing anyone can do is to laugh
at you
and it's not
laughing in isolation
with a comedian
it's laughing at you
and and that i don't think is acceptable
i
i don't deserve it
i don't
warrant it
i don't want it
i i wrote a new verse for john lennon's
imagine
imagine there's no gender it's easy if
you try no trans no gayness no lesbian
no bye imagine all the people living
life at ease
yeah
you're a songwriter no not at all
why do you think you get abuse online
because you talked about abuse online
why
why
does it matter to other people yeah how
you are i don't know i think it's just
like it just goes back to that like
toxic masculine behavior like a lot of
the comments i get online are from like
straight men and
you know they'll like tag their friends
in my videos or pictures and be like can
you believe that's a man or whatever and
it's like
i don't know like i just feel like
people are trying to impress their
friends
so they're like oh look at this look at
this but it's not big and it's not
clever so you know you can keep saying
what you want but
yeah i think and also i think
people aren't educated and it does take
people like you
to educate them there was a famous
english philosopher called john dunn who
said that no man is an island of himself
and we are all islands but if you think
about islands they're all joined to
every other island under the sea you
just can't see the join people are
joined to each other we need to respect
each other as being different and yet
so similar so joined together what i do
affects you what you do affects me and
other people
what would you say to someone
young that's watching this right now
that kind of has those feelings of
confusion
what would you say to them there is
information available there are people
to talk with
if you are confused about your sex
gender
then find somebody
to talk with
who will listen
to you
i would just say it's probably so cliche
to say but like it gets better like it
really does get better like the world is
changing the world is becoming a better
place
i would just say like hold on to like
being trans don't feel like you're a
freak don't feel like you're weird
like use your uniqueness to get where
you want in life like use it as a
positive thing and i think once you
start using something that makes you
unique from everybody else
then you're like you can just thrive so
i think you know
don't be too hard on yourself
speak to your friends speak to your
family
and if someone doesn't accept you then
can i swear yeah
[Laughter]
millions of people potentially watch
this video
what can
the people watching this video do
to help further trans rights
there is petitions out there for you to
sign that makes a massive difference
like you might think it's not something
good but
i mean one
signature makes a whole load of
difference and even sharing that so
because i'm trans on my social media a
lot of people follow me because i'm
trans and
but if someone that isn't trans shared
it to their story or to their profile
they have a whole different reach to
what i do so they're like you know their
brothers their sisters their family
their friends are going to see that
and
cisgender people which if people don't
know what that is that means someone
that is
you know born a woman and completely
feels like a woman and their gender
aligns with what they're born as
so
you can put something out there that
other people are gonna see
and also like i think a big thing as
well is if you see someone say something
bad or you know a situation happen
literally call it out because if you
don't that person is still going to be
in the dark of what the right terms are
or
what
how to go about things so you know
so there are activist things that people
can do but most importantly is
whoever you see
you see a person you see a human being
that human being deserves respect
and acceptance
whatever their color whatever their
religion whatever their gender sexuality
whatever
that can be done by anyone at any time
and should be done
who does your makeup
is is your hair your own natural color
um
wow and they want to know well
when you had surgery
have you got the same as me and the
answer is yes but i don't have the messy
bits